Settle down. The weekend doesn't
begin until at least after the 3.
91 lecture. Work first, then play.
A couple of announcements, next
Tuesday, quiz two based on the
subject matter of homework two,
the periodic table tests will be on
Thursday, and it's going to be not
before too long that we'll have time
for the monthly test,
the first monthly test.
The mnemonics contest deadline is a
week from today at 5:00.
Send it to me by e-mail if you want
to win that hot tie or that hot
scarf. It's come to my attention
that people are moving freely about
recitations without arranging
through my office.
And, some of the recitations
sections are uncomfortably large,
which defeats the purpose of the
recitation in part.
I mean, we want you to have access
to the instructor and if you have 30
students there instead of 20,
that dilutes your access.
So, we insist that you go to the
section that you are assigned to.
And, if you must change because
you've got a UROP,
or you've got some other activity.
Please do it through my office so
that we can make the learning
experience good for the majority and
not just for the few.
Oh, there was something else I
think.
Yes, I just learned yesterday that
to my somewhat disappointment,
you know my favorite transuranic
element is 111 because it's
unununium. But,
it has been isolated by the team in
Darmstadt in Germany and they have
proposed the name roentgenium after
Wilhelm Rontgen,
who is the discoverer of x-rays.
And, that's now before the
International Union of Pure and
Applied Chemistry.
So, maybe before the fall is out
we'll have to change.
I already showed you that this is
now darmstadtium.
So, we're going to have a whole
bunch of, it looks like,
Meitnerium. So, there's going to be
a whole bunch of German names along
here pretty soon.
So, somebody better get busy over
in Berkeley. What are they doing
there? What's going on?
Anybody know? People are sleeping.
OK, so let's get to the lesson.
Last day, we studied the Bohr model
for one electron atoms.
And, the Bohr model showed us that
through the quantum condition,
all of these quantities were
quantized.
They were functions of the quantum
number, n. And,
later in the lecture,
and later in the lecture,
we began to look for reconciliation
between the Bohr model and Balmer's
analysis of Angstrom's spectral line
study of the atomic hydrogen.
And, so we looked at the prism
spectrograph, and the gas discharge
tube, and I showed you the
energetics of what goes on in there.
And, towards the end of the lecture,
we started talking about the actual
energetics of collision.
And, I want to return to that.
So, let's put up that sketch again
where we're looking at the incident
electron. And,
this is the electron that is
accelerating off the cathode.
There is electrons all over, and I
want to make sure we are not
confusing one electron for another.
So, this electron I'm talking about
here is this one that is moving off
the cathode and towards the anode.
And, en route is going to collide
with some atomic hydrogen.
So, this is the incident electron.
And, it has kinetic energy of, I'm
going to denote it E incident,
one half mv squared **E=1/2 mv^2**.
It's not bound. It's moving along.
And let's subscript this as well.
Incident velocity,
electron rest mass,
incident energy.
And, it's going to collide with a
hydrogen atom at some point.
I'm going to draw the hydrogen
schematically like this with a
proton in the nucleus,
and a lone electron in some orbit
here. And, if the energy of the
incident electron is greater than
the energy required for some
transition within the hydrogen,
then it's possible that this
electron will capture some of the
energy from the incident electron,
and be excited to some other state.
So, let's put that on.
Let's call this some initial state,
and let's call this some final state.
And, that's only going to occur
when this incident energy is greater
than the energy of transition.
So, we've got two electrons here.
Here's a moving electron, free
electron.
This one is bound.
So, this is in the target,
or in the specimen, which in this
case is atomic hydrogen.
So, let's look at what happens here.
The excitation occurs.
And we can get the energy required
for this transition by using the
Bohr model. The Bohr model gives
this value, and gives the value as,
that came right out of the
postulates, the delta E of
transition is going to equal -K.
I'm putting it up generally,
z squared to allow for a higher z
level, one electron atoms.
And, it's one over final quantum
number squared minus one over
initial quantum number squared.
So, that gives you the amount of
energy. And, that energy is going
to be taken away from the kinetic
energy of the incident electron,
which then will make its merry way
off after the collision.
And, I'm purposely making that
vector shorter to indicate that this
electron has been slowed.
And, we call this electron the
scattered electron scattered by the
collision with the target hydrogen.
And, it has kinetic energy E sub
scattered as one half mv squared
scattered. The mass of the electron
doesn't change,
but its velocity certainly decreases
as a result of this collision.
But, that's not the end of the
story.
That's not the end of the story.
What happens here is that this
electron that's excited is there in
an unsustainable basis.
It's just a one-shot deal.
So, the electron wants to fall back
down to the lower energy state,
and it does so. It falls back down,
and when it does so, it gives off
that energy in the form of a photon.
So, we have an emitted photon,
and it has energy h nu or hc over
lambda, or hc nu bar.
And, it is the set of these emitted
photons that Angstrom studied.
Angstrom was studying these emitted
photons. And,
clearly, there is some relationship
between the wavelengths that he
observed, and energy levels within
the atomic hydrogen.
And, all of this,
this whole process is subject to
conservation. So,
let's get that up. Let's make sure
that we don't violate any basic law.
So, we're going to say that the
energy of the incident electron will
then be spread across the electron
energy of transition within the
target. And, whatever's left over
will remain with the electron at
some reduced value.
And, what I've shown here,
I'm applying it to the experiment
that Angstrom conducted in which he
accelerated electrons.
But, it's the same calculation for
any particle. So,
this is for all incident particles
would be subject to this.
All incident particles, so,
it could be obviously electrons.
We could accelerate protons.
We could accelerate neutrons.
We could accelerate alpha particles.
We could accelerate argon ions.
There's a host of incident
particles. Consider them only as
bearers of energy.
They are energy transfer vehicles,
and they transfer energy here,
provided that the energy is high
enough to cause excitation.
Now, another way of looking at it
conceptually is this is a probe beam,
a probe beam, or maybe a stimulus.
And, the integral of the energy of
the particle after interaction and
the emitted photons,
that collectivity is the response.
This is the response, OK? This is
the response. So,
what does this mean?
This means that we could
interrogate some atom of unknown
identity, and on the basis of these
values, infer,
deduce the identity of that species.
And, we talked at the end of last
day about how this is applied in
analyzing the chemical composition
of stars. So,
the radiation goes a long way,
and we're able to use the
information contained therein to
conduct analyses.
So, let's see how this will help us
reconcile the Bohr model to Balmer's
analysis of Angstrom's data.
So, let's see.
I think we have to go back to the
Bohr model. If we go over to Bohr,
this thing's decided that it wants
to sleep. Finally.
See, it's Friday. The computer has
decided it's going to goof off a
little bit. So,
we're going to use postulate number
six in order to help elucidate
what's going on here so we can then
resume here and say that delta E of
the transition is the energy of the
final state minus the energy
of the initial state.
That's always the case.
We always say that the difference
goes final minus initial.
And, we can represent that as the
product, kZ squared,
one over n final squared minus one
over initial squared.
And, conservation of energy says
that must be the value of the energy
imparted to the emitted photons.
So, the emitted photon, E of the
photon, this is emitted when the
electron cascades back down.
And that will be hc over lambda.
So, let's flip this thing around.
Let's flip this thing around, and
what we'll get that is nu bar,
or one over lambda. Then will be kZ
squared over the product of the
Planck constant times the speed of
light, one over n final squared
minus one over n initial squared.
Now, for the Balmer series,
for Balmer series, we had this set
of lines for which the n member was
always n equals two.
So, we're dealing with atomic
hydrogen. So,
let's put Z equals one.
And, let's put the final state as n
equals two. And,
furthermore, if we evaluate k over
hc using values that
we already know,
We get 1.1 times ten to the seven
reciprocal meters.
So, if you put all that in,
you get 1.1 times ten to the plus
seven, one over two squared minus
one over ni squared.
And, ni has to be greater than nf.
So, that necessarily means that it
must begin at three.
It could go four, five,
etc. Well, that's exactly the
Balmer formula.
We've got the Balmer lines out of
the Bohr model,
identical to Balmer.
So, Bohr has been able to reconcile
with Angstrom's data taken half a
century earlier.
But furthermore,
Bohr suggests other experiments.
For example, doesn't it bother you
that the lines end at n equals two?
You know that according to the
energetics here,
the electrons have to keep cascading
down to n equals one.
I mean, is there something funny
going on in Sweden?
Maybe the electrons in Sweden,
they are a little bit nervous.
Maybe it's winter.
Maybe they are afraid to go down n
equals one. How come we only get n
equals two? Well,
let's look for a second here.
Look at this. The sleep function
is kicking in.
I see the hard drive.
There we go.
So, let's for a moment take a look
at the electromagnetic spectrum.
This is taken from your book. And
you see, again,
I'm thinking about you all the time.
I got out my pens, and I've colored
it in. The doctor says this is good.
It's very good.
So, here we are with wavelengths on
the upper trace showing wavelength
increasing from right to left,
and energy increases from left to
right. So, high energy is low
wavelength. One point here that
irritates me: the SI unit of
frequency is hertz which
means beats per second.
It's not the per-second.
This is a little sloppiness on the
part of the textbook.
And so, here what we've got is at
the very, very low end of wavelength,
very high energy are gamma rays,
cosmic rays, and then over here at
the low end of energy are the gentle
forms of radiation,
radio, TV, microwaves over here,
and then in the center as it's drawn
is visible light. And
I want to expand that.
And, here's the visible spectrum,
which in round numbers, I'd like you
to know a little bit of this.
I think an educated person should
know a few things here.
And, round numbers, visible
spectrum runs from about 400 nm up
to about 700 nm.
And so, the blue is low wavelength.
It's high energy, and red is high
wavelength, low energy.
And, here it is staggered from one
end to the other.
And so, what we have here is
actually an indication of what our
photodetectors are capable of
sensing. We are tuned to operate
here, and it's no accident that we
are maximally positioned here in
green, we are very sensitive in the
green. We don't have uniform
sensitivity. It maxes in green.
So, the green pointer is a very
good pointer to use.
So, now let's go over to the
experiment. We can convert this to
electron volts,
by the way. I think electron volts
is a good way to view this.
And, you can see that visible
spectrum stands roughly two to three
electron volts,
two to three electron volts.
And, think about it. Think about
already this little paradigm here
I've shown you,
something excites.
Something gives off photon.
What about the inverse? Photon
comes in; something excites.
Wouldn't it make sense to have
photodetectors that operate at
around two to three electron volts?
We are going to see later on in
3.091 that semiconductors have band
gaps roughly in this regime.
OK, so what's this have to do with
n equals two? Well,
this is taken from your textbook.
And here's the Balmer series ending
in n equals two.
If you convert these transitions,
n equals three to n equals two, that
turns out to give you an energy on
the order of something between 400
and 700 nanometers.
And, what was the sensor that
Angstrom was using?
He was using photographic film.
And, photographic film is sensitive
in the visible.
So, the electrons in Sweden were
falling down to n equals one.
But, look what happens. When you
fall down to n equals one,
look at these wavelengths.
100 nm, well, where does the 100 nm
put you? Way over here.
You are in the ultraviolet.
So, the photographic detector
doesn't pick them up.
And likewise, some of the electrons
were promoted even higher than n
equals four, n equals five.
And, on their way down, they were
landing on n equals three.
So you say, well, why didn't he get
a set of lines where sometimes you
get one over three squared?
Well, let's take a look.
Let's take a look. If you go down
to n equals three,
that's called the Paschen series.
And, look at these numbers, these 1,
75 nm? 1,875 nm,
that puts you way over here in the
infrared. So,
n equals two, those four lines end
up right in the middle of the
visible spectrum.
And, that's why the lines that
Angstrom measured were in that
regime. So, we can generalize all
of this in the following equation,
nu bar, which is the wave number,
goes as R times Z squared one over
nf squared minus one
over ni squared.
And, this is known as the Rydberg
Equation in honor of Professor
Rydberg. Another Swede,
he was at the University of Lund.
And he was also active in
spectroscopy.
And so, we encapsulate everything
that's on this slide here is in this
equation, and more so because this
allows for higher Z elements besides
just elemental hydrogen.
Well, there is still more evidence.
There is still more evidence in
support of Bohr.
Let's take a look at that.
Bohr was really riding high.
This was good, but it gets better.
It gets better.
There is the Franck-Hertz experiment.
Franck-Hertz experiment was
performed in Berlin around 1912 to
1914. So, it was published around
1914. And, what Franck and Hertz
did was operate a gas discharge tube.
But, instead of running it with
hydrogen, they filled it with
mercury vapor.
Now, mercury, as you will learn
later in its vapor state exists as
the single atom.
It's like helium,
single atom, whereas hydrogen,
there is atomic hydrogen. There is
a molecular hydrogen.
So, they operated gas discharge
tube with mercury vapor.
And, what did they find?
What they found was that when they
varied - so let's draw this
little schematic here.
They've got a variable voltage power
supply feeding electrodes.
We've got mercury in here,
cathode, anode. And, they put up an
ammeter in the circuit.
And, they measured the current
voltage characteristic.
So, here's the current.
It goes through the cell,
electrons moving off the cathode
shooting across to the anode.
And they measured the current as a
function of voltage.
And, what they found was that at
low voltage, you get low current and
at higher voltage you get higher
current as you'd expect,
some kind of an ohmic behavior.
Up to some critical voltage, and at
that point the current dropped to
almost zero. And,
the tube started glowing blinding
white. This turns out
to be about 4.9 volts.
They continued raising the voltage,
and again, now they've got current
going through,
the ammeter is registering current.
The tube is glowing, and now, the
current is rising until another
critical voltage.
And then it falls again.
And now, the tube is glowing even
brighter. And,
this is 6.7 volts.
And just for your information,
you look on the periodic table today
and it turns out that the ionization
voltage for mercury is about 10.
eV. 10.4 eV is the ionization
energy.
So, this is below the ionization
energy. So, what's going on here?
What they reasoned was, they were
exciting bound electrons within
mercury, and furthermore that there
are critical voltages associated
with critical energies.
Conclusion: there are quantized
energy levels within mercury,
which is to say that the Bohr
postulate of quantization applies
not only to a one electron atom.
But it applies to multi-electron
atoms. Well, if it applies to
multi-electron atoms,
doesn't that mean it applies to
everything? So,
they concluded from this experiment,
quantization of energies of
electrons in multi-electron atoms.
So, the Bohr model doesn't apply to
multi-electron atoms,
but the assumption that energy is
quantized in multi-electron atoms,
the assumption of energy
quantization extends to
multi-electron atoms.
So, this is really, really good.
Bohr was riding very, very high.
But, all good things come to an end.
There were problems with the Bohr
model too. So, now let's
look at limitations.
I want to look at limitations of the
Bohr model. Limitations of Bohr.
OK, first of all, there's data out
there. There's data out there
already, first 1887.
1887 Michelson and Morley,
this work was distinguished by the
fact that it was done
in the United States.
You notice, most of everything I've
shown you up until now was done in
Europe with one exception,
the Millikan experiment in Chicago.
Everything else is European science.
But, Michelson had immigrated to
the United States and was really,
really clever. He was brilliant
inventor, was doing military
research for the Navy back in the
early 1880's. He invented the
interferometer.
And, he was the first to make
accurate measurements of the speed
of light, the Michelson
interferometer.
And, he eventually worked at the
Case School of Applied Science in
Cleveland, which ultimately became
Case Western Reserve University
after a number of transitions.
So, he was working at Case in
Cleveland, and doing very,
very high precision spectroscopy.
That was his forte. He was a
brilliant experimentalist,
knew how to make equipment that was
highly accurate.
And, what he found was that one of
Angstrom's lines,
the line associated with the
transition three to two,
if you look really, really carefully,
now remember, Angstrom made the
measurements by looking at light
hitting a photographic plate.
And, that light doesn't come down
nice and sharp.
There is a little bit of scatter in
the data. So,
you get this fat line.
But the positions of center to
center on the lines follow that set
of four numbers that we were
looking at yesterday.
Now, what Michelson redid the work,
remember, Angstrom did his
experiments in 1853.
Michelson looks very,
very carefully and sees that it's
not one line, but that it's two
lines, two lines very close together.
So, the three to two line is in
fact a doublet.
It's a doublet,
that is to say, two lines very,
very close together. But from a
distance, it looks like a line.
And then, if you've got really
accurate instrumentation,
you discover that it's a doublet.
And that's a problem.
That's a problem because if you
look at this term scheme here,
if we've got a doublet, it means
that you've got two different
transitions. So,
the Bohr model is saying you go from
n equals two up to n equals three.
And, when you fall from three back
down to two, you give off a photon.
And that photon has a unique value
of wavelength.
But, they're measuring two.
But they're very close.
So, what that suggests is that maybe
there are two levels that are really,
really close together.
And, sometimes the electron falls
from the higher level.
And, sometimes it falls from the
lower level. But in any event,
there must be more than one level,
but very close together. So, Bohr
is silent on that.
Now, the other possibility is that
two is the problem.
We don't know. Maybe this has got
two lines, and this has one.
So, that's the point, first of all.
By the way, Michelson was awarded
the Nobel Prize in 1907, not
for this observation.
He got it for the measurement of the
speed of light.
Why I'm putting it down is you are
going to see everybody today.
We are giving out Nobels like
they're going out of style.
So, everybody gets a Nobel today.
It's not like Oprah; we're not
giving everybody a car.
But we're going to give everybody a
Nobel, OK? So,
that's the first piece of bad news
for Bohr. These are headaches for
Bohr. OK, number two:
number two is 1896.
1896: Pete Zeeman,
who is a postdoc at Leyden in the
Netherlands, he was a postdoc at
Leyden in the Netherlands.
And, what he did, these people were
so creative. I mean,
they were so excited about science.
So, he works with a gas discharge
tube, and he takes the gas discharge
tube and he puts it into a magnetic
field. He makes the magnetic field
by wrapping a conductor around the
tube and passing current
through the conductor.
And, by playing with the value of
the current through the coil,
he changes the intensity of magnetic
field, and then goes through the
experiments with the prism
spectrograph. OK,
so he measures gas discharge tube,
same thing all over again, gas
discharge tube in a magnetic field.
And, what he observes is the
following.
Just schematically,
if this is the photographic plate,
and you've got multiple lines on the
photographic plate,
this is no magnetic field,
what we've seen before. What he
finds is that in the magnetic field,
some of these lines actually, and
this is not to scale,
some of these lines actually show up
as doublets, triplets,
but only in the applied magnetic
field. So, we call this line
splitting, which is even different
from what Morley said.
Michelson and Morley observed that
no magnetic field,
if you look carefully,
there's multiple lines.
What Zeeman sees is that single
line, no magnetic field.
Apply a magnetic field, you see a
line splitting.
And, furthermore,
he found that the intensity of the
magnetic field affected the degree
of splitting. The higher the
magnetic field,
the greater the degree of splitting,
line splitting proportional to
intensity of magnetic field.
So, this is called the Zeeman effect.
And, that's not bad for a postdoc
because he got a Nobel in 1902,
and they were only offered for the
first time in 1901,
so talk about a meteoric rise.
People obviously on the Nobel
committee thought this was pretty
good work. So,
how's the Bohr model going to
describe this?
It can't. It's incapable of
describing this effect.
There is more.
People are looking; they're working
hard. So, 1913,
I'm even going to give you the month.
November 1913,
why am I giving you the month?
Because the paper was published in
July of 1913, Bohr's paper,
July 1913. November 1913 there is a
fellow by the name of Starck,
and he's doing some work at Aachen
in Germany.
And, analogous to what Zeeman was
doing, Starck takes gas discharge
tube and he puts it between plates
that are connected to a power supply.
So then, he subjects the gas in the
tube to an electric field.
And, what does he observe?
Line splitting. And, how is the
line splitting?
The more intense the applied
electric field,
the greater the line splitting.
So, same thing.
Line splitting in electric field.
It's known as the Starck effect.
And, you guessed it: he gets a Nobel.
Everybody's getting Nobels.
1919 he gets a Nobel for the Starck
effect. So, all of this is adding
up to, there's good news here.
Bohr was able to give us a sense of
what was going on in the Angstrom
experiment, but there's a lot of
stuff here indicating that it's an
incomplete model.
So, 1916, a theoretician comes to
the rescue, Arnold Sommerfeld.
He was a professor of physics in
Munich. And he proposed some
modifications to the Bohr model.
He liked the Bohr model. He didn't
want to throw it out.
He liked the concept of a planetary
model. But then maybe he looked to
the heavens. You know Kepler's laws
of planetary motion.
What's the orbit that the planets
describe? It's an ellipse,
ellipsoidal. So, Sommerfeld said,
how about this? Just suppose, and
this is not to scale.
It's going to be exaggerated so you
get a sense of it.
Suppose in addition to a spherical
orbit, suppose the electron might
describe an elliptical orbit.
Now, overall, this is roughly the
same. It's not super elliptical.
It's just mildly elliptical, but
just enough that it's not
exactly spherical.
So, this could give you sort of have
your cake and eat it too.
You could say, this is the
principal quantum number of Bohr.
It's n. But, within n there's a
little bit of fine structure.
Fine structure, that is to say,
there are details there that the
first pass didn't quite capture.
So, suppose we have more than one.
Maybe we have a plurality
of elliptical orbits.
So, we have elliptical orbits.
But, they are roughly of the same
dimension as the original circular
orbit. And, he says we have sort of
a band. And he calls this a shell
containing multiple orbits,
which he termed orbitals to
distinguish them from the
circular orbits of Bohr.
Why did he call it a shell model?
He said, think about the eggshell.
The eggshell: we can describe it
but the eggshell itself has some
thickness. So,
this is a sense of what Sommerfeld
was giving us.
So, he says, how am I going to
capture these ideas quantitatively?
Well, the shell could be captured
by the quantity n,
but these orbitals,
some of them circular,
some of them elliptical; I'm going
to need new quantum numbers in order
to capture these new ideas.
And so, let's take a look at the
quantum numbers that Sommerfeld gave
us. So, the first one is N,
and it is as it was in the case of
the Bohr model.
So, this is called the principal
quantum number or the shell quantum
number, principal or shell
quantum number.
And, it talks about size.
It talks about size, the size,
that is to say the distance from the
nucleus to the shell.
And, it takes values one,
two, three, and so on up to infinity.
And at infinity,
we're talking about a free electron.
And, in parallel, there is another
notation that's used that
spectroscopists came up with,
their own notation. They don't like
numbers. The spectroscopists
used letters.
But the spectroscopists,
they're a funny bunch. They're very
suspicious. So,
here's what happened.
If you look on this chart here,
for a while we thought Balmer was
the bottom of the barrel.
But that's n equals two. And then,
when the detectors got better, we
saw that n equals one.
So, the spectroscopists said what
if somebody comes along with an even
better detector and finds
transitions to energy levels below
that which we are calling one?
So, we are going to get ready.
We are going to give letters to
these, and they started with the
letter K because it's somewhere in
the middle of the alphabet.
So, if we ever discover an energy
level lower than n equals one,
we can use a letter. It will be the
J. So, there's K,
L, M, and this notation is used to
this day. When we talk about x-rays,
x-rays generated by electrons
falling down to ground state are
called K x-rays.
So, this is the other notation for
the values that n can take.
Now, let's get into the
contributions of Sommerfeld.
He called the next quantum number
lowercase l. And,
this is the orbital quantum number,
the orbital quantum number, and it
describes the shape of the orbital.
Remember, I said we needed some way
to distinguish purely circular from
elliptical or other shape orbitals.
And, the orbital quantum number
takes values zero,
one, two, up to the value of n minus
one.
And, the spectroscopists use letters.
They refuse to use numbers.
They're very numerophobic (sic).
So, the use lowercase letters to
distinguish the orbital quantum
number from the principal quantum
number. And so,
when l equals zero,
it's lowercase s for sharp because
these would be very sharp lines.
Then, p for l equals one, which is
principal, d for l equals two,
which stands for diffuse, and f
which stands for fundamental because
by the time you get up to f level,
you've got such compression that all
of the spectral lines are starting
to look very similar to those of
hydrogen, which is the fundamental
spectrum of all time.
And then, after that,
they go g, h because they ran out of
ideas. So, that was it,
OK? So, now let's take a look.
When l equals zero, this means you
have a spherical or circular,
a spherical orbit or a circular
orbit.
And that's easy to remember because
O is, think of it as a perfect
sphere. All right,
when L equals one, this is
elliptical. You have an elliptical
orbit. You can think of that,
zero is zero, and one, think of that
as there's some elongation,
OK? And, when L equals two,
when L equals two, I'll show you
these later in about a week's time.
They're just much more complex.
You get dumbbell shaped,
doughnut shaped, and all sorts of
things. So, just say they're more
complex. So, those are the numbers
associated with certain shapes of
the orbital. Then,
the next quantum number he gave us
was m, which was the magnetic
quantum number.
It's the magnetic quantum number,
and it speaks to the question of
orientation.
And, the admissible values of m are
l, l minus one through zero down to
minus l. So, spanning from plus l
to minus l, and of course l is
subject to values of n.
So, in the case of n equals one,
when n equals one, l can equal only
zero. So, if l is zero,
then this value, m must always be
zero.
And, indeed this confirms the
observations. There was no line
splitting in a magnetic field for
the ground state.
It wasn't seen. What happens when
n equals two? When n equals two,
well, l can take values of one and
zero. So, what do we have?
We have now n equals two, l equals
one, so, m can now go one,
zero, and minus one.
So, this is the one case where there
is some value in thinking about the
Cartesian equivalent of this.
It's very dangerous when you're
talking about quantum ideas to try
to ascribe physical attributes to
them because in many cases,
it just doesn't work. But, in this
case, I think it does.
So, let's look at three values of
the magnetic quantum number when we
have an elliptical orbit,
right? So, one way of thinking
about it is here are the three
principal coordinate directions,
X, Y, and Z.
Now, I don't know where real X lies,
but once I choose X, I can use the
right-hand rule,
and I know where Y and Z have to be.
They're orthogonal. So, if this is
X, this is Y, this is Z.
I have a non-spherical,
non-axisymmetric orbital.
So, for simplicity, I'm going to
just make it elongated,
OK? Well, what does this say?
It says m can go one, zero, minus
one, which to my mind represents the
fact that there are three principal
coordinate directions in which you
can orient that.
So, I think this is a nice example
of mathematics imitating reality.
OK, after that, it gets very messy.
And then, the last quantum number,
this is where Sommerfeld left it.
But I'll finish by introducing the
last quantum number.
The last quantum number came a
little bit later.
It's a lowercase s,
which is the spin quantum number.
And, it represents the fact that the
electron is considered to have spin.
And it takes values plus or minus
one half. And here's the basis for
this value here.
I want to put this all together so
that I'm doing a little bit of back
to the future because this is 1916.
That's where Sommerfeld leaves it.
This comes about 1925,
but I want you to have all quantum
numbers.
And then, we can move forward.
And what introduced this was an
experiment conducted by Stern and
Gerlach in Frankfurt,
and that was done around 1921.
We can wake this up; we'll have a
look at it. This is cute.
I think it's cute. We'll see.
You don't laugh at any of my jokes,
but this is Sommerfeld on the
occasion of his 80th birthday.
And as is the custom for her
birthday so momentous as this,
people from all over the world get
together for a party.
And they accompany this with a two
or three day affair in which people
give scientific papers in honor of
the celebrant.
So, this is taken from the book
that was published on the occasion
of Sommerfeld's 80th birthday.
And, since Sommerfeld was the one
that proposed that orbits could be
spherical or elliptical,
they as a gag said, well,
here's Sommerfeld, and then here's
Sommerfeld somewhat distended.
So, this is l equals zero,
and this is l equals one, and this
was accompanied by the inscription
that said Sommerfeld was the one who
taught us that the circle is the
degenerate form of the ellipse.
And, that was really funny. That's
1920s geek humor.
That was roaring.
But clearly it doesn't age well.
You're not sensing this. OK,
here's the Stern-Gerlach experiment,
very, very cool experiment.
They were doing studies in the early
20s to try to validate Maxwell's
equations. So,
what they've got over here is a
furnace with a crucible of liquid
metal. And, the metal has obviously
a vapor pressure above it.
And, there's a slit here. And,
they've got a beam. It's like a
physical vapor deposition.
And so, they're shooting metal in a
beam over to a cooled substrate here.
And, they're analyzing the deposit.
OK, so if you shoot a beam and it's
got a slit, you should just get a
shadow of the slit.
So now, let's get interesting.
Let's test Maxwell's equations.
So, they send the beam through a
divergent magnetic field.
You can see the South Pole comes to
a point. And the North Pole is a
curve. So, the field lines had to
diverge. So, they were asking
questions like,
what happens if you take a beam of
metal and send it through?
And here's what they found.
What they found was really, really
interesting. If you take a metal
and send it with no magnetic field,
and you look at what you get on the
substrate, this is the
shadow of the slit.
In other words,
if you send it through a narrow slit,
this will be the deposit of the
metal. When B does not equal zero,
they observe a deflection. So, now,
the question is, if here's the rest
position of the beam,
in which direction should the
deflection go?
And, so some would argue,
well, it should go up, and some
argued that it should go down.
And, what they found was they found
two, a single beam split into two.
And, this really vexed people.
In fact, here are the data. This
is a very grainy reproduction from
their paper. The dark line is a
trace of the deposit,
in this case, it's silver.
They are sending silver through
with no magnetic field and now,
here it is with the magnetic field
on. And this is a grating.
And they are measuring separation.
So, the silver beam splits into two.
It goes up and down.
So, Goudsmit and Uhlenbeck come
along. Let's get these guys on here
first. This is Stern and Gerlach,
1921, and, yeah, so they're working
on that one. And then comes
Goudsmit and Uhlenbeck also at
Leiden, again. They were
two graduate students.
And they said,
we can explain that.
Watch this. Crazy as it sounds,
here's the electron moving around.
They said the electron just doesn't
move, it spins.
They said what is the electron is
spinning as it moves around the
nucleus, all right?
And, if you use the right-hand rule,
if it's spinning clockwise,
it's spinning up. But maybe an
electron, we don't know where the
absolute up or the absolute down is.
Some electrons might be spinning
anticlockwise,
in which case they are spinning down.
And, silver is atomic number 47.
So, it has an odd number of
electrons. So,
it can't get a spin up electron
canceling a spin-down electron.
It has a net non-paired spin, and
they said, well,
since we don't know what the
absolute is, half of the silvers are
spin up, and half of the silvers are
spin down. And that's why you get
this. So, let's give a fourth
quantum number.
Let's call it plus or minus one
half. And, you could
say this is crazy.
But, it explains those results.
And, they actually were here during
World War II. Both of them,
they worked down just around the
corner here in the Rad Lab,
radiation laboratory where radar was
discovered. It's around building
four, first floor.
There's a plaque there indicating
it. OK, well let's jump ahead.
I want to talk a little bit about
hydrogen and energy and I want to
talk about the Hindenburg.
The Hindenburg was a giant,
rigid airship. To give you a sense
of scale, it was almost as long as
the Titanic: 135 feet in
diameter, 804 feet long.
This is a 747 dwarfed.
7 million cubic feet of gas,
112 tons of useful lift. But,
they inflated it with hydrogen
because the Nazis had come to power.
Most of the helium was to be found
in the United States.
And, Congress passed the Helium
Control Act, which forbade the sale
of helium to Germany.
So, the engineers said,
OK, we'll use hydrogen.
So, they filled this thing with
molecular hydrogen.
And, I mean, it was a fantastic
boon. I mean,
these are posters from that era: two
and a half days to Europe,
only two and a half days, much
faster than going by ship.
Here's a sketch. This is in German,
and now over the North Atlantic,
there's the tip of Manhattan.
There's a nice shot of the airship
over Manhattan.
So, it made ten transatlantic
flights in '36 carrying almost 1,
00 passengers, cruising speed 78
miles an hour.
They only flew in summer.
So, it's the arrival of the first
flight to the US on May 6,
1937. And, it's docking at
Lakehurst, New Jersey.
The docking was moved.
If you go to the top of the Empire
State building and you look out,
you'll see these protrusions. Those
protrusions were put there in the
expectation that zeppelin airships,
dirigible airships would dock at the
Empire State building.
People would get off, take the
elevator, and next thing you know,
you're on Fifth Avenue.
When they tried to dock these things,
the air currents were so turbulent
that it was unsafe to do so.
So, they made this docking station
across the river in Lakehurst.
So, this is what happens: 36 dead.
That's not what's amazing. It's
amazing that the majority of people
disembarked. What I want to tell
you is it was not an explosion.
The Hindenburg did not explode.
There was an aluminum grand piano on
there. They had ballrooms.
They had restaurants. You were
there for two and a half days.
You're dressed. It's elegant.
The aluminum piano melted. They
figured what happened was there was
electric discharge in the vicinity
of a tiny hydrogen leak.
Hydrogen is a tiny molecule,
and some hydrogen must have been
leaking. They think it may have
been something like a St.
Elmo's fire or something like that,
just a high electrical discharge and
the misfortune that this thing
caught. So, here's the analysis.
This skin was made of resin, and it
was finished with a lacquer dope to
make it water repellent.
And, to make it glow,
they used aluminum powder in the
lacquer dope. And then,
they put iron oxide on the inside.
Lord knows why. So, you basically
have the elements of a thermite
reaction. This is what the shuttle
uses, in its solid rocket boosters.
So, once this thing caught, it was
the skin that went.
And of course this meant the end of
rigid airships and commercial air
transportation,
and to point out that it wasn't the
hydrogen.
If that had exploded,
it would have been a very different
scene. This is 1956,
a U.S. Navy airship dirigible filled
with helium; same thing,
but it had a two ply cotton envelope.
Gasoline fire: away it goes.
So, it was the skin. In fact,
100% hydrogen will quench flame.
It's like running a carburetor too
rich. You choke.
You need fuel plus oxygen.
You cannot get 7 million cubic feet
of oxygen to the site to
sustain the explosion.
Besides, you're working with only
20% oxygen in air.
This, I blew it up because I
thought this would look sort of like
modern art. So,
there it is. This is a Roman candle.
It's not an explosion.
If this had been an explosion it
would have been totally different.
So, this is stoichiometry. This is
a limited reaction.
There was not enough oxygen to keep
it going. So, there it is.
Have a nice weekend.